después de la emoción de los goles
pasemos ahora a la economía hablamos
aquí en el estudio con Jorge Hurtado
Jorge muy buenas noches iniciamos con
uno de los puntos de la agenda de la
visita del presidente francés Emmanuel
macocó a Estados Unidos Cuál es de qué
se trata bueno se trata de la ley para
la reducción de la inflación de Estados
Unidos una medida que ha sido criticada
por el gobierno francés el gobierno de
Estados Unidos defendió su plan
económico para combatir la inflación y
el cambio climático que Francia acusa de
ser una medida proteccionista es en una
llamada telefónica con periodistas un
alto funcionario de la Casa Blanca
aseguró que la ley presenta
oportunidades para las empresas europeas
y que van a trabajar para según ellos
ayudar a los europeos a entender la
mejor la ley incluye ayudas a empresas
que inviertan en tecnologías limpias
entrará en vigor el 1 de enero de 2023 y
contempla subvenciones millonarias a
empresas que inviertan en Estados Unidos
el programa es atractivo para empresas
europeas que se beneficiarían por los
precios de la energía en Estados Unidos
que son menores que en Europa pero el
ministro de economía y finanzas Bruno
lemer de Francia quiere que la Unión
Europea diga a Estados Unidos que su
programa o su ley no es aceptable la ley
contempla 7.500 dólares por ejemplo en
subsidios a quienes compren vehículos
eléctricos fabricados y en suelo
estadounidense esto supone un golpe duro
para el sector Automotriz europeo donde
Francia y Alemania son importantes
productores varios países europeos creen
que Estados Unidos está tomando una
ventaja comercial sobre la Unión Europea
Incluso en noviembre pasado el mismo
presidente francés dijo que la medida no
está en línea con las reglas de la
Organización Mundial de comercio y
tampoco con la amistad pasemos ahora a
hablar del fondo monetario internacional
que podría recortar sus previsiones de
crecimiento para china importante esto
para la economía mundial bueno los datos
irían a revisión tras las protestas en
contra de las estrictas políticas de
China para combatir el covid 19 en
octubre el fmi recortó su previsión para
la segunda Economía del mundo al 3,2%
anual afectado por las políticas de
covid 0 así como por la desaceleración
del sector inmobiliario ahora la
previsión es que el crecimiento de China
aumenta el 4,4% el próximo año pero el
Duro enfoque de Beijing consiste en
obligar a los gobiernos locales a
imponer cierres repentinos y cuarentenas
algo que crea el descontento social
escuchemos así que tenía que decir
cristalina York lleva presidenta del
fondo monetario internacional
lo que está impulsando esta
desaceleración del crecimiento dos
factores uno las restricciones
relacionadas con covid Zero y dos las
dificultades en el sector inmobiliario
China tiene espacio fiscal para impulsar
su economía y contrarrestar cualquier
presión para que el crecimiento baje
to go down esta noticia es importante no
solo por el mundial de Qatar 2022 sino
también por la crisis energética de este
país de medio oriente firmó un acuerdo
para suministrar gas licuado a Alemania
por 15 años bueno Y es que aunque no
especificaron el valor en dólares de
este acuerdo se sabe que comenzaría en
2026 es parte del esfuerzo de esta
potencia económica europea para
reemplazar el gas ruso que ha sido
afectado por la guerra en Ucrania
Qatar enviaría hasta dos millones de
toneladas de gas a Alemania las empresas
involucradas son catara Energy la
empresa estatal del país Cómo conozco
Phillips que tiene participaciones en el
yacimiento de gas natural de Qatar en el
Golfo Pérsico que comparte con Irán como
reacción al apoyo de occidente a Ucrania
Rusia recortó el suministro de gas
natural utilizado para calentar los
hogares generar electricidad y alimentar
las empresas en Alemania esto ha creado
una crisis energética que ha empujado la
inflación y ha aumentado también la
presión sobre las empresas a medida que
aumentan los precios Alemania que
recibía más de la mitad de su gas de
Rusia antes de la guerra desde finales
de agosto no recibe gas ruso ahora el
suministro de gas alemán procede de
Noruega los Países Bajos y Bélgica o
pasa Por alguno de ellos pasemos ahora a
la región de América Latina porque en
Chile Los camioneros terminaron con esa
huelga que tenían en diferentes regiones
del país llegaron a un acuerdo con el
gobierno y con los empresarios bueno el
acuerdo terminó con ocho días de
movilizaciones y el retorno a la cierta
normalidad en las principales carreteras
de ese país el acuerdo aborda Los
reclamos de los listas Para mayor
seguridad de las rutas y los constantes
aumentos de precio de los combustibles
este último negociado directamente con
los empresarios que fijan los precios
tras la firma se congelará el precio del
combustible durante cuatro meses una
Elsa tope de 15 pesos por litro cada 21
días y una inyección de 1.500 millones
de dólares al mecanismo de
estabilización de precios de los
combustibles las protestas habían ya ha
provocado algunas en algunas ciudades
que resistieron el desabastecimiento
sobre todo de alimentos y también de
combustibles Muchas gracias Jorge por
esta actualización a continuación en
directo América el debate
[Música]